[Applause]
everyone please give a warm welcome to
theo rocky
[Applause]
um
theo is it we had a story in the news
today about um snl's uh pete davidson
and colin jost buying the new boat to go
back and forth from staten island and
entertain and comedy and party and drink
and like have the best time ever but
you're from staten island
yes and is it true that you didn't like
grow up necessarily around a bunch of
arty people and did not see this as your
future
have you spent a lot of time in staten
island
not not enough
but i'm getting on that boat no no no
you're never getting off it um that's
true i'll go back and forth and then go
staten island is um
its own world
it's a part of new york city but it's
not part of new york city it's just a
different kind of place and a different
it's it's an amazing place to grow up
because it was kind of like a throwback
especially for me 80s 90s kind of being
outside all the time and doing whatever
neighborhoods and all that and then you
still had access to the city but no i
had never i had never met anyone
my mom my mom's a dressmaker she went to
fit you know she really yeah yeah so
cool yeah my mom was like a total she's
a beast she's like the most powerful
woman on the planet like you know in
every single way that was the only thing
that kept me around art okay i love the
way you speak about your mother but i
also fell in love with the way you speak
about your father yeah and
your parenting style will you talk to us
about that
yeah i mean listen i you know i my
father left
when i was
probably really left when i was eight
you know and now as a much older uh
person can look back and say it's the
best thing that ever happened to me
when i was young it didn't feel like it
but the reason i say it's the best thing
is i would never be the father i am to
my two sons if he didn't
i would never
be able i wouldn't be sitting here with
you because the truth is him leaving and
potentially that longing for a figure
had made me a better artist how do you
know how to be a great parent
if you don't come from bad parenting
okay
in a very platonic your wife first kind
of a way i love you
um
i i'm so moved by that uh
now
you're from staten island but is it true
now you live in austin texas i do yeah
we live on a ranch yeah it's amazing and
you kind of just disappear once you get
in and the kids are like wildlings you
know it's like lord of the flies with
these two boys i mean their hair is down
to here and they're just like covered in
mud like you know
at night you're just trying to get a
decent amount of mud off them when
they're in the bath and they're just
yeah they're wild they're wild i love
them so much i always tell my kids i'm
like if you're dirty it was a good day
yeah
and there i mean i i left to fly here
you know last night and i was still
putting up the zip line like that we're
doing this 100 foot zip line yeah there
we we grow all our own food and yeah we
have we're it's it's crazy yeah it
really is lord of the flies and it's uh
and i'm you know i'm just so happy with
how they
are able to just get out there and in a
world that's gotten
it's gotten so big right the world has
gotten so big but yet so small right
they could dive into an ipad and get
lost or whatever they're out there you
know picking up worms and learning about
how to work the garden and we go out on
our walks all day with the dogs we're
about to adopt a bunch of donkeys and
chickens and goats and they're just kind
of like in it and i love that is it true
your wife wants to maybe have one more
child well
well that's up to her that has nothing
to do with me i'm just an innocent
bystander and all that
how would you feel if you had another i
mean it just
do like if you had another boy what
would that journey be if you had a girl
what would that draw i would love to
have a girl i just thought i heard her
raised by women i would love to have a
girl i mean if girls got all together
they would just take over the world
anyway so i might as well
i mean yeah
theo do you just get people to fall in
love with you everywhere you go you're
such an amazing person
well yeah tell my wife that keep telling
that she needs to hear it i have a
feeling she knows it if she wants to
keep nesting and you know trust me
that's a good sign
[Music]